[Musique]
ce mercredi 24 août le département
annoncé la cinquième édition du salon
des seniors aux côtés de l'adere
l'association pour le développement et
le rayonnement de la réunion l'occasion
pour les seniors de rencontres et
d'échangés autour des thématiques du
bien vieillir et du bien-être en
vieillissant nouveauté cette année la
manifestation se déroulera en quatre
dates à saint-leu saint-denis
saint-andré puis au tampon le salon des
seniors vous serez à la fois des
associations principalement des
collectivités et surtout les les
organismes qui rompt pouvant apporter
toutes les informations concernant le
bien vieillir et le bien-être donc pour
pour nos seniors d'autres by aura
également des petits marchés forains il
y aura également des conférences y aura
également des services à la personne et
donc tous ceux qui ont qui se posent des
questions pourront avoir trouvé des
réponses à leurs questions concernant le
bien vieillir le bien-être en
vieillissant afin de permettre au plus
grand nombre d'y assister l'entrée sera
gratuite pour tout public une mesure
possible grâce à la prise en charge du
département à hauteur de 155 mille euros
le prix initialement c'était 2 2 euros
nous nous voulons que tout le monde
puisse accéder à ce salon des seniors
c'est un salon qui est dédié allume à
l'humanité réunionnaise aux personnes
qui vivent sur ce territoire de la
réunion et donc
renom l'ouverture l'ouverture est l'axé
vol plus grand nombre donc les 2 euros
disparaissent l'entrée sera gratuite et
le gratuit tu vois tout le monde pour
les personnes âgées comme pour les plus
jeunes tout public voulant accéder au
salon des seniors b pourra le faire de
façon gratuite
le premier rendez vous de cette tournée
se fera à saint-leu ce dimanche 28 août
au parc du 20 décembre de 9h à 17h
non